we are still all trying to deal with
Carl getting bit and I think it's
seismic like you know it was been shot
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead choral episode two
most important lines probably from the
episode one I got bit in - good morning
darlin I love that twist at the end but
if you've read the comics and you have
an idea for how they might bring that
about but we also finally got an
explainer for what these fuzzy
flash-forwards are they've seemed like
dream sequences now we learn whose
perspective we're actually seeing when
we're seeing this so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet
and I'll also address all the lauren
cohan maggie news the fact that she
hasn't renewed her contract for season
nine so she might be leaving the show
too but she wasn't featured in the
episode there a number of ways that they
could deal with that so there's a lot of
stuff happening behind the scenes at the
walking-dead a lot of big changes but
let's do top 10 WTF and comic book
Easter eggs there were mostly a lot of
callbacks to earlier moments on the show
like back during season three that was
Jody that he was talking about but
number 10 as has become their trademark
signature they opened with a POV shot of
them jumping around in time so because
it's Carl's episode we're viewing it
from his perspective and it's basically
the events leading up to the beginning
of episode eight before the big battle
happened and I love the way that he just
casually goes about his day like oh it's
no big deal that I got bit I'm gonna
have some fun with my sister Judith take
some pictures with her I'm gonna go hide
Siddiq down in the sewers share some of
my KitKat with him that I've changed the
name of for brand safety so that we
don't get sued by the makers of KitKat
like it's just this totally normal day
Michonne drives by he waived her it was
totally surreal but number eight we also
get a Morgan flashback because he had a
parallel arc in this episode it was sort
of this juxtaposition of people that
were willing to do things to make the
world a better place and people who were
not willing or could not find it in
themselves to do the right thing like by
the end of the episode where Morgan is
like I'm sorry I have to
he had some mad kills in this episode
though I love the trap that he sets as
he's rushing out but all that's taking
place before present day is not till
number seven when Carl's in the sewer
saying I got bit that they actually pick
up in the moments right after the end of
episode 8 so they're like on the sewer
they're still in shock from finding out
that Carl's been bit a source explaining
Siddiq how he rescued him how he got bit
what the letters mean and slowly starts
the process of him saying goodbye to all
the people and they start to make a plan
for what they're gonna do next like
number 6 all of us together will be
their worst nightmare so Darrell still
ramping up for a fight remember parallel
arcs the really hardcore people that are
still towing the status quo just kill
anybody who is against us in the people
who are willing to try and work with the
other people like bridge a gap to make
the world a better place so I feel like
your enjoyment of the episode and the
way you feel about the characters just
depends on which side of that fence you
fall on like is coral correct or should
we be taking Daryl's route in Morgan's
route and just killing all those people
even the people that we don't need to
kill the plan now is that they're all
heading to hilltop that's why Daryl said
all of us together their worst nightmare
so that's where the next big fight is
supposed to take place but number 5
Morgan is like the new Terminator so
they're making their way to Ezekiel
they're just trying to rescue him that's
all the mission is about they're not
trying to get rid of the Savior's they
just want to get Ezekiel and get out
because he sacrificed himself so that
all those other kingdom people that
Carol was with earlier at the beginning
of the episode could get away but this
hilarious thing happens with Morgan
hilarious and horrifying where he just
slowly goes around killing every person
you could imagine imagine he's in like
an open-world game just going around
killing all the NPC's even though
they're not mission objectives like oh I
got to wrack up these other kills so I
can get my score up even though I'm not
gonna get any special bonus points for
this but it really starts to turn when
he kills those two here and Carol just
stares at him for a minute like the
camera pauses and you see that look on
her face like what's going on he's going
crazy and he almost jeopardizes the
mission gets himself killed because he
goes to kill that other group Carol has
to save him from that bullet but it's
all part of that downward progression as
he spirals out of control till we get to
that Gavin moment at the end of the
episode so it's all in service of that
he just gets progressively more in more
horror
core by about halfway through the
episode when Carl started saying his
actual goodbyes to the big characters
like giving baby Judith Rick's sheriff's
hat this is really when the episode
started to take a turn for cry worthy
like progressively down to when you
actually hear Carl start to talk about
all these moments that he had in the
past when he first got the sheriff's hat
back during season two if you remember
the TV show changed the way that it
happened in the comics a little bit on
the TV show Carl had been shot he'd been
recovering and they joked that they had
this shared experience now father and
son so it was sort of him acknowledging
Carl becoming a man becoming a big tough
guy but he was still really really young
then later when he was talking about
some of the regrets that haunted him he
talked about Jodie back during the
season 3 finale welcome to the tombs he
was part of the governor's army he was
trying to surrender and was like this
really hardcore turned for Carl's
character because he's still this tiny
little kid look at the baby face that he
has with the sheriff's hat on in this
giant gun and frame it was meant to be
really badass in the moment but now he
completely recontextualizes that by
saying that I've thought about that
moment ever since then and it's haunted
him so every time when you go back and
you watch those season 4 episodes where
he's railing on Rick for not being more
proactive he admits that Rick was right
that whole time and not wanting to fight
but number 3 this is probably one of the
best WTF moments that The Walking Dead
has had in a long time when they're
fighting inside the theatre where
Ezekiel is being held captive in Morgan
just reaches into that dudes open wound
and Yanks his guts out and everyone
freezes all the Savior's that are still
in the room like Gavin Ezekiel and Carol
all have these looks of disgust in
horror on their faces in Morgan just
shakes his head like it's no big deal
alright let's go and just casually walks
away from the body after Gavin who has
just like taken off like piece I'm
tapping out this is way too hardcore for
me and that just goes after him like
Omar on the wire my number 2 was Karl
saying his final goodbyes to Rick and
Michonne and sort of telling him about
the visions of the future that he had
sort of letting us know that we've
always been seeing Karl's perspective
when we see these dream sequences it's
not Rick imagining these moments and
it's not the actual future it's the
future that Karl dreamt that they could
have in Rick says I'm
going to make it a reality so when we
see number one WTF negan at the end of
the episode
good mornin darlin like he's been
completely rehabilitated and he's an
upstanding member of the community
that's not reality that's something that
Carl hopes could happen someday because
he is narrating all this and Rick says
I'll make it happen but then you sort of
hear that gunshot and it's Karl killing
himself with Rick's gun and Rick just
lying there after they dig the grave
like he can barely handle this now how
is he gonna deal with this next week the
promise that he makes to Carl is that
he's gonna bring this into reality so I
think the idea is is that the actual
future will look something like this but
it'll be a little bit more comic book II
so if you've read the comics then you
might have an idea for how negan ends up
with the survivors albeit with a very
different twist like the things that he
does with them in the comics are vastly
different than what's happening at
Carl's visions so I don't want to get
into big comic book spoilers and please
if you have read the comics use spoiler
tags in the comments if you want to talk
about negan's future because I do the
shows probably gonna go a couple more
seasons so we'll find out what
eventually happens to negan we'll get to
whispers we'll do all that stuff but
just to talk about the reason why people
are so mad at the show for killing Carl
is if you haven't read the comics Carl
is essentially the future of the comic
book so for the most part you've gone
along this whole time thinking that Rick
is the main character of the series but
the whole idea in the comic book is that
eventually Carl will take over but like
in the comic book they chopped off
Rick's hand they didn't do it on the TV
show for mostly practical reasons so
imagine Rick dying and giving that
speech to Carl and Carl saying I'm going
to do everything I can to make this
future a reality the reason why I think
that AMC sort of flipped the comic book
script is is because they believe from a
business perspective Andrew Lincoln is
more bankable as the leader of the show
as opposed to say Chandler Riggs who's
still technically a child actor so I
think it's mostly long-term business
reasons that AMC opted to go this
direction so I'll totally understand if
you're really upset that they killed
Karloff Chandler Riggs said that he
didn't know that this was gonna happen
when they had their initial story
meetings for Season eight but I think
they can bring him back in flashback so
we'll see Chandler Riggs on the show
again every once in a while but it'll
only be when Rick is
remembering him like when they brought
Herschel back after they killed him
during season 4 well let me know in the
comments what was your biggest WTF from
the episode and if you want me to keep
doing weekly Walking Dead videos
obviously I'll still do videos for at
least every couple of episodes but just
depending on how much everyone really
wants to talk about the show I'll just
adjust the level of videos that I do so
more videos less videos no big deal
totally fine but if you didn't see it
click here to learn all about that big
Captain America easter egg during black
panther and click here for brand new
flash because that is back this week too
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight